Parfois, quand on commence des recherches
sur un personnage dont la vie semble particulièrement
intéressante, hors du commun...
On se rend compte qu'il y a une autre couche
de génialitude derrière, et encore une autre...
Et tout cela nous amène à notre Gente Dame
Badass du jour: Mary Wollstonecraft.
Née le 27 avril 1759 près de Londres, elle
bascule d'une famille aisée à la ruine à
cause des mauvais placements de son père,
qui est en plus un homme alcoolique et violent.
A 19 ans, elle quitte sa famille pour devenir
demoiselle de compagnie à Bath, auprès d'une
veuve qui ne lui rend pas la vie plus facile.
Elle revient à Londres en 1780 pour assister
aux derniers moments de sa mère, puis se
cherche tout en vivant chez les Blood, une
famille à laquelle elle est très attachée.
Elle fonde une école avec la fille de la
famille, Fanny, mais cette époque plutôt
agréable se termine en 1785 à la mort de
Fanny.
Elle devient alors gouvernante en Irlande,
encore une fois dans une famille difficile,
et c'est à partir de cette expérience et
de toutes les précédentes qu'elle décide
de tout envoyer valser et de devenir écrivain.
Ça faisait un moment déjà que Mary construisait
et affirmait ses opinions sur la société,
de par ses études, ses lectures lorsqu'elle
vivait chez les Blood...
Elle est particulièrement énervée par la
condition féminine de l'époque, décrivant
la «Situation malheureuse des personnes
de sexe féminin, ayant reçu une bonne éducation
et laissées sans fortune». Elle retourne
vivre à Londres, apprend le français et
l'allemand et vit principalement de traductions
et de critiques littéraires, au début:
être autrice au XVIIIe siècle et réussir
à en vivre est très rare.
Elle fréquente des philosophes et personnages
importants de la littérature de l'époque,
comme Joseph Johnson, son éditeur qui devient
pour elle un mentor.
Elle publie Pensées sur l'éducation des
filles, encore peu engagé, ainsi qu'un recueil
de contes didactiques encore une fois destinés
à l'éducation des enfants.
Sa notoriété grandit en 1792 avec la publication
de Défense des droits des femmes, un ouvrage
qui soutien l'éducation des femmes.
Il est rédigé en réponse à plusieurs écrits
conservateurs, dont le rapport Talleyrand
de 1791 qui affirmait que les femmes ne devraient
recevoir qu'une éducation à caractère domestique.
C'est cet écrit qui lui vaut d'être parfois
décrite comme la première féministe anglaise,
même si le terme est anachronique à l'époque.
Elle critique l'idée que les femmes seraient
inaptes à étudier car trop souvent guidées
par leurs émotions.
Pour voir de ses propres yeux les événements,
en France, qui ont inspiré son livre, et
à cause d'une déception amoureuse, elle
part s'installer à Paris, en pleine Révolution.
Là elle rencontre un aventurier américain,
Gilbert Imlay, dont elle a une fille en 1794.
A la même date elle accouche d'un nouveau
livre, An historical and moral view of the
French Revolution, mais les tensions en France
la forcent à rentrer en Angleterre.
A partir de cette date elle se fait appeler
Mrs Imlay, même si elle et Gilbert ne se
sont jamais mariés et se séparent peu après,
pour légitimer sa fille Fanny.
Sa rupture est très dure pour elle et renforce
un état dépressif dont elle souffre probablement
toute sa vie et attention, on va aborder un
sujet sensible.
Si vous êtes vous-même dépressif, vous
pouvez zapper à ce time code.
Là.
Elle fait une tentative de suicide, puis se
rend en Scandinavie pour tenter de mener des
transactions financières qui pourraient aider
Imlay.
Elle publie son plus gros succès, Lettres
écrites en Suède, en Norvège et au Danemark,
à partir de ce voyage, mais constate à son
retour que sa relation avec Imlay est définitivement
terminée et tente cette fois de se jeter
dans la Tamise d'où elle est sauvée par
un inconnu.
«La seule chose que je doive déplorer,
c'est que, alors que l'amertume de la mort
était déjà derrière moi, j'ai été inhumainement
ramenée à la vie et à la souffrance.
Mais une ferme détermination ne doit pas
être troublée par la déception; et je
ne permettrai pas non plus que mon acte soit
considéré comme une tentative hystérique,
car il s'est agi d'un acte de raison, décidé
dans le plus grand calme.
Sur ce point, je n'ai de comptes à rendre
qu'à moi-même.
Si je me souciais de ce qu'on nomme la réputation,
ce serait pour d'autres choses que celle-là
que je mériterais le déshonneur.»
Elle revient néanmoins dans le cercle littéraire
dont elle faisait partie avant son séjour
en France, et se rapproche de plus en plus
de William Godwin, un philosophe réputé
et précurseur des pensées anarchistes.
Elle tombe enceinte, ils décident de se marier
pour légitimer leur enfant à venir, mais
cela révèle qu'elle n'avait jamais été
mariée à Imlay: ils perdent donc quelques
amis dans l'affaire mais sont heureux, ils
s'installent dans deux maisons côte à côte
et apprécient cette relation où chacun garde
une grande part de liberté.
Malheureusement, Mary accouche de sa fille,
Mary également, le 30 août 1797.
Elle meurt de fièvre dix jours plus tard.
Son histoire, cependant, ne s'arrête pas
à cette vie intense mais brève.
Godwin, qui passe le reste de sa vie à entretenir
la mémoire de sa femme, publie en 1798 Memoirs
of the Author of a Vindication of the Rights
of Woman.
Son intention était de rendre hommage à
Mary, en racontant tous les aspects de sa
vie, mais dans le même temps il jette une
ombre sur May Wollstonecraft pour de nombreuses
années: beaucoup de lecteurs sont choqués
par sa libéralité, sa fille illégitime,
ses liaisons amoureuses et ses tentatives
de suicide, qui étaient encore inconnues
du grand public.
A cause de ça, sa réputation est foutue
en l'air jusqu'à la fin du XIXe siècle et
ses écrits sont très peu lus.
Elle commence à être réhabilitée par Millicent
Fawcett, suffragette très influente que vous
devez connaître et qui rédige l'introduction
de la réédition de 1892 de la Défense des
droits des femmes.
Elle occupe maintenant sa juste place dans
l'histoire du féminisme.
Blâmée pour sa vie décousue, à l'écart
des conventions sociales, sa mémoire salie
alors même que son mari tentait de la passer
à la postérité, Mary Wollstonecraft a pourtant
laissé des écrits importants sur l'éducation
féminine qui continuent de nous inspirer.
«Endoctrinées dès leur enfance à croire
que la beauté est le sceptre de la femme,
leur esprit prend la forme de leur corps et,
enfermé dans cette cage dorée, ne cherche
qu'à décorer sa prison». Elle critique
aussi le mariage en tant qu'institution patriarcale,
notamment dans ses romans, ce qui lui vaut
ainsi qu'à Godwin des reproches lorsqu'ils
décident de se marier.
Choisir de ne pas se marier lui aurait fait
courir le risque de perdre une bonne partie
de ses relations, comme c'est le cas lorsqu'il
devient connu qu'elle n'avait pas épousé
Imlay.
Cette incitation aux bonnes mœurs reste en
vigueur pendant très longtemps et nous la
retrouveront dans le prochain Gentes Dames
Badass: quand je disais en début de vidéo
qu'il arrive que, couche après couche, on
découvre la complexité d'un personnage historique,
je ne parlais pas de Mary Wollstonecraft.
J'ai beaucoup aimé l'étudier et découvrir
ses idées, que je tenais à partager avec
vous, mais je l'ai découverte en faisant
des recherches sur l'autre Mary de notre histoire.
Mary Wollstonecraft-Godwin, sa fille, qui
devient par la suite Mary Shelley, après
une histoire tout aussi mouvementée que celle
de sa mère.
Dans le prochain Gentes Dames Badass on parlera
donc de Mary Shelley, et de l'histoire de
la création de Frankenstein.